please give a big warm Scottish welcome
to Harry okay Harry
we see you the 35 year old ginger is
dropping his royal title and going by
one name now
like Madonna Adele and Cher we learned
of Harry's name change on Wednesday
during his introduction at an
eco-tourism summit in Scotland he's made
it clear that we are all just to call
him Harry the appearance marked his
first since relocating to Canada with
wife Megan Markel and their son Archie
Thank You Aisha and good morning
everyone here he gave a brief welcome to
the crowd on behalf of his travel
conservation programme travela style' et
have learned that Harry is absolutely
practicing what he preaches
he flew commercial and then took a train
to Edinboro for the summit according to
our source this wasn't a formal
engagement for Harry and he's not making
any official speeches or participating
on any panels as for Megan the source
adds that she didn't go to Scotland with
Harry and he's expected back in London
later today where the couple will carry
out their final royal engagements we're
a fantastic team we know real up next
Terry's scheduled to meet with Jon Bon
Jovi later this week and Abbey Road
Studios the two are teaming up for
Harry's beloved Invictus games something
the Sussex is teased on Instagram last
week with the hilarious and fictitious
text exchanged between Harry and Bon
Jovi I was wondering what do I call him
now on Wednesday the 57 year old
musician joked about Harry dropping his
royal title during an appearance on a UK
radio show and I've come up with the
idea he's going to be known as the
artist formerly known as Prince of
course Harry and Megan announced their
plans to step down as senior members of
the royal family last month and will
split their time between Canada
and the UK going forward I heard that
helps you understand what did it come to
that I would step my family back from
all I have ever known
just stick is to take a step forward
into what I hope can be a more peaceful
life
[Music]